[Music]
let's talk about the Blair Witch Project
in 1999 this movie got a lot of hype for
creating a lot of scares with a less
than minimal budget it was shot mostly
on a video camera and start 3 film
students in the middle of the woods
audiences even to this day a rather
split about it
some call it one of the scariest movies
of all time while others say it's just a
shakey cam vomiting mess
whatever people's thoughts there's no
denying it had a huge impact not only
did the movie make a ton of money but it
also inspired the home video horror
genre you know films like Cloverfield
The Last Exorcism and of course
Paranormal Activity all of them pulling
off big Hollywood scares with a home
video touch well just a mere 1 year
later after the film's release artisan
came along and said hey if they made a
bundle with little money and clever
ideas surely we can do the opposite with
the sequel well - that is what we're
doing
[Applause]
[Music]
no those direct-to-dvd sequels well this
is one of those directed garbage can
sequels
it looks so rushed so half bad and so
having little to do with the original
that you'd swear they took a totally
different movie and just let the words
Blair Witch to honestly you know
something like The Departed language to
alien versus Predator way which to or
Toy Story to Blair which toe so let's
see how desperate they were to get this
piece of shit out there
this is Book of Shadows by oh2 so we
start off with oh god I hate these yeah
I guess it really happened whoa
funny I thought I saw one of the
original actors on The Late Late Show
the other night but hey maybe it was her
goes so it's a fictionalized event based
on a real-life event that was always a
fictionalized event I hid it just from
reading the credits
we start off with some news footage
showing how the Blair Witch Project was
also a movie in this world
however they stand by the fact that it
was entirely real critics who called it
one of scariest films of all time
I was terrified oh it scared me to death
read documentary filmmakers heading to
the Black Hills forest of Maryland movie
night
so now Blair Witch fans are not only
flocking to the multiplex they are
flooding the little town of
Burkittsville Maryland people have
started coming to Burkittsville as if it
were trials Manson's the Spahn Ranch or
Ed Gein the serial killers house to
visit so well you might think this is a
goddamn commercial for the first film
again the actual story does get rolling
sort of okay now I guess it's one year
earlier from summer 1999 I guess as we
see doctors performing College pranks on
their patients not that I don't trust a
psychiatric center where the doctors
smoke and pour egg drop soup in what I
can only describe as an astral Blanc but
quite frankly I think I'd be safer in
the hands of dr. Howard dr. fine - dr.
Howard
don't even bother with it dates anymore
the people who actually cared enough to
do the math I crying in the corner
shooting blood out their ears good kid
so it turns out the Blair Witch tour is
on the way this calls for some
despicably force dialogue introducing
our characters ladies and gentlemen put
your hands together for mr. Stephen Ryan
Parker
apparently he's here researching a book
with his girlfriend Blair Witch history
or hysteria
you've always been misunderstood we
embrace nature Thank You Erica not only
a hottie but a real witch
blessed be we can so we have two
pretentious authors a pretentious Wiccan
a pretentious filmmaker and of course
their mangy dog movie do we do well
thank God their last pickup isn't the
least bit potential I'm just gonna take
a guess and say somebody in this group
wants attention my hand I want em feta
maids weed is what I've got beer I'm
gonna get both now so teaching Chung's
Blair Witch tour keeps on moving as they
talk by a grocery store hell of a town
you got here
what century are they living in ha
freaks they get their stuff together and
get ready to head out into the woods
what's up with all his camera stuff to
record all occult phenomena that may
manifest itself in the course of the
tour yeah you're really running bullshit
central here aren't you
everyone's just walking around like a
bunch of conformist go ahead and wear
your business suits you can make $34,000
a year and buy your condominium they're
all zombies racing to their graves so
how far along are you
what do you mean the baby how many weeks
six how do you know I don't know so
apparently you want enough mascara leaks
into your brain you get psychic powers
actually that's what makes sense the
more thing about it piece released the
energy that be
you're casting some kind of evil spell
communing with a weak Edward the Blair
Witch
I thought you embraced nature or not
evil yeah you don't understand
Ellie it was a good witch now you force
me to play this are you a good witch or
a bad witch
you keep wrapping these jokes for me you
know she was an earth child like me
she's gonna be my mentor to shed my
mortal coil and commune with Ellie
bitch what you want I mean seriously
you're starting to make this chick look
like the sensible one make her sound
helpless I thought witches could summon
powerful energy we can but we still have
to eat shit and die like the rest you
just look good doing it
Tino you can either acknowledge this for
the self-indulgent didi bullshit that it
is or you can be quickly enchanted by it
so whimsically John in by what cheese
sounds god you're falling for it we just
look good doing it Oh witches are so as
is typical of any a well paid tour guide
he whips out the weed and alcohol and
they party like it's 1999
[Laughter]
okay Bermuda Triangle
it's a place in the world that's been
created by hysteria okay what was it the
editing in camerawork it's actually
worse than the other movie I mean that
was three kids with a camcorder they had
an excuse this this is a movie an actual
movie and yet they're terrified for some
reason to hold on the same image for
more than four seconds the movies not
gonna eat you if you hold that extra
five okay this whole Blair Witch thing
has set us back 300 years it's like
we're back in the burning times it just
totally fucked up our image
people fear but they don't understand
you got to realize that life is pain
life is only pain we're all taught to
believe in happy fairytale endings but
there's only blackness
oh shit people say that I I drink blood
that I sacrifice children that I worship
the devil just because I'm a Wiccan and
that's where I come from people think
that because I dress in black that I'm
just kind of sick killer or something
new because you dress in black we think
you're pretentiously hilarious but it
turns out another group of idiots comes
waltzing their way we got a tour group
The Blair Witch walk what's your Excuse
tour group the player which we have
jurisdiction here we have Hermits oh
yeah from Cravens bullshit let me see
them bullshit ex-husband you come on
pablo manson berlin you came all the way
from berlin to see this don't have
crappy sequels out there - been
exhausting you cunt
what's with the whole you didn't come
out here just to look at trees thing did
you see the first movie for 20 minutes I
know the boy wait with the grass and you
guys take the Blair Witch walk alright
yeah next time you go from there which
one here's my card you can call me I'm
on the web so the author has a dream
that she walks into a pond it drowns her
baby it's always pleasant when they wake
up the next morning and find what I
assume is the shredded remains a play
which three this is my work
this is all my research we must have
fallen asleep asleep it's like we must
have blacked out I don't even get it
somebody ripped it apart and then snowed
it on them that's so like in high school
when a bully used to tear up my homework
and then ground it into transparent fog
some people are so abstractly and
considerate at least the tapes are still
here what the tapes they're here well
we're in my mind I see them and for $2 a
minute I can tell you more they're there
Jesus Christ how did you know I don't
know did you put them in there did you
excuse me I got a job but it looks like
the author is in the process of having a
miscarriage
again very pleasant and seems to be
seeing strange images while at the
hospital
[Music]
yeah I forgot to mention they cut
endlessly to the sacrificing of these
people that we don't see it they don't
tie it into what's going on at the
moment like that all they just show it
out of nowhere completely at random and
then come back to the movie like
nothing's happened sometimes it's just a
microsecond like look at this scene from
earlier man I hear voices all the time
[Music]
you see what that have to do with
anything what did that add even if it's
a scene from another part of the movie
they don't work it in very well imagine
if Ninja Turtles start showing scenes
from their climax all throughout the
movie because the outside
Oh Dumars because the outside world
this is your family okay seriously
nobody saw that at all okay where was I
you're here because Elsa were rejected
oh yeah this is your family
Oh tell me you didn't see that nothing
any of you okay fucking bathrooms to
your left
we're fighting Turtles yeah the
miscarriage sucks
let's connected as little as we get into
the rest of the story now we're going to
your house
yeah RFD 431 Jericho Mills home the
filmmaker takes them to his living place
which is actually a pretty freakin cool
setup oh there's an old factory just
after the Civil War they were gonna tear
it down but I talked him into selling to
me for a buck a buck they sold you a
Civil War factory for a box such a
ridiculous deal please you gotta help
old Gil what's it gonna take to keep you
on the phone you dance for you but you
wouldn't even see it yeah all right I'm
dancing yeah yeah yeah it did it you're
walking into the official Blair store
okay we got paaru infante ssin dirt
that's a big item I saw that t-shirts
this is what the Wiccan religion really
needs Jeff more capitalism based on fear
and lies I mean do you really think it's
fair to like exploit our culture just to
sell a bunch of stick-figure keychains
okay I have no idea how the Wicca
culture works or want to step on
anyone's believes but no thought oh yeah
chick is annoying
she's like an earth child version of
Jessie from Saved by the Bell
t-shirts or nature or just get the
camera off of her
[Music]
so he just forgets about the creepy girl
they just saw outside and tries to make
his girlfriend feel better all while
battling the continuing terror of
shopping flashbacks come on penny come
you're not making a believer out of me
son it was an accident
it's a rock to say it really cracks me
up the way he says I swear to Christ it
sounds like he's turning into Miss Piggy
doesn't it
what more strangeness occurs as they
play the video footage back see that oh
wait look
timecode goes from 1:32 a.m. to 357 am
back to 1:32 a.m. oh gee is it annoying
and frustrating when the timecode just
jumps around like that the fucking
audience feels so will they continue to
analyze the footage Erica and Steve have
a wicked good time in the back
[Music]
uh nothing like the good old my
girlfriend just had a miscarriage and
now I want to fuck a reject from the
Kraft rebound this becoming more popular
[Music]
about this better make fuckin sense
later or else
now I'm gonna yell about and this was
last night yeah during the big blackout
so they look at the footage and see an
image of Erika dancing around naked if
this is a joke it ain't funny Wow she
really is Jessie from Saved by the Bell
super pretentious over-the-top and she
made the transition into horrible
striptease I didn't do that
Erica that's you right there on the
screen you should see the footage of me
when I'm drunk I'm gonna be pulling off
they get alcohol tell me right now tell
me right now your stop drinking tell me
your so drinking tell me right now time
so we're trying to figure out what's
going on the goth chick goes to the
store where the exact same people are oh
my god do they ever leave the store
you can't keep cheating upskirt shot for
ever their grandpa I have a problem with
you two so the cashier refuses to ring
her up so the gut chick takes a bite
force I've touched me again and I will
rip out your goddamn throat keep your
motherfucking chance
[Applause]
meanwhile Erica starts going crazy
because she doesn't remember dancing
around like a moon whore or whatever she
call it Stephanie I invoke the earth and
fire and smoke Persephone
[Music]
but early the next morning they look
outside and find their van is totally
destroyed now to do to my van you said
you just busted up the front end a
little I swear it was just the front
fender so the Blair Witch is actually
Bigfoot from monster truck rally cuz
that would be freaking awesome other
strange things start happening like how
they all discovered that they have scars
on their bodies in the shape of Wicca
symbols can't believe we didn't notice
those before where is Erica
my god it's a classic case of drive-by
shooting properly ee so aside from the
AL crashing the miscarriage and the
totally insane hysterical visions I had
to admit this is pretty good tour but
it's not over yet as they hear even more
crazy sounds and be waiting from outside
Thank You chicken don't come after me
you know who it is and you know what you
have to do so the bridge breaks but the
boyfriend makes it out okay we don't cut
to the author inside whoo okay we really
supposed to take this seriously with
that going on you can tell us we're
supposed to laugh at that right but you
think that's weird remember the bridge
that just broke a second ago it's back
up Hey look I'll put your dog's barking
at the house Paul I'll show those damn
little okay I'll give this film credit
that I have absolutely no idea what the
bad fuck is going on but all I gotta say
is it had better be building up to
something
a good something oh hey Eric is dead oh
what a shame I never got to use my
witch-hazel clip so as things get
crazier and crazier the gut chick has
what else a crazy idea we need to take
the tapes we need to run them backwards
why I I don't know I think it's gonna
help us find out what happened to Erica
so if I wanted the footage backwards
funny cuz the timecode says it's going
forward that somehow shows what happened
after they blacked out
he just looks like your everyday
reenactment of Caligula but it seems
like the author is the ringleader
commanding them to cut themselves and do
her bidding but of course they don't
remember any of it and think she's to
blame because of the video footage and
with that they suddenly get their
memories back that they actually killed
the other tour group that night they
blacked out okay fine
why did you have to cut to that all
throughout the movie or maybe they
didn't in the coast was in the editing
room oh just a few miles from the town
of Burkittsville where just hours ago
police arrested three obsessed movie
fans who allegedly committed a series of
ritualistic murders after watching last
summer's blockbuster movie The Blair
Witch Project whoa who will simply
commit suicide ahead yeah video tapes
slap together over Montgomery College
right you see how fucking insane tristin
was watch the tapes you'll see so so
sure of questions then we finally see
the quote-unquote twist ending this
movie has
that's right they were killing the
people the whole time and they didn't
even know it tour group the woman at the
counter
Erica even the author it turns out was
never taunting them at all wrong believe
it or not that's where it ends folks
right there
okay well all and all the more think
about it I think they actually wrapped
up all the questions pretty well oh
except what's that the Blair Witch who
was behind it the whole time did that
when Pete's girl had anything to do with
it oh and what about the author was he
possessed or behind it at all actually
whoever it was what was the motive why
kill all these people
were they under a spell or just crazy I
mean we know that this guy was crazy
because he was in a mental institution
in fact what was up with that opening
with the pouring of the mucus into his
nose they never explained that hey how
come they so crazy images sometimes and
then didn't and other times was there
ever a rhyme or reason to it or did they
just do it out of nowhere for that
matter how do we know the video footage
is really what we're seeing I mean is
that really what happened or did the
ghost or witch or whatever it is play
with that too we saw clearly he can miss
with the footage speaking of which why
was the footage will be playable when
being played backwards and even then how
did they see the snippets of it when
they were playing it forward oh yeah and
did they ever explain why the goth chick
was psych-k palette Serling back story
wasn't it I'm so glad they had bad in
the movie that was essential to the plot
hey is there a chance you can explain
why you were cutting to those bits of
those people being murdered out of
nowhere did it add anything to the story
did it create any suspense now that I
think about it from a storytelling point
of view what does this have to do with
the fucking Blair Witch the connection
if there is one at all is barely made in
fact wait a minute never mention that in
the movie why the hell was that the
title they never talked about it we
never even see it don't you think maybe
the title of your movies your godamn has
something well fuck shit damn to do with
your movie it's never explained hey you
know what come to think about guys mommy
has bad ass it makes no sense
the characters are obnoxious the editing
is beyond annoying
it's just a crazy stupid fat-ass sequel
the idea of doing a sequel based around
the phenomenon a Blair Witch it's kind
of clever maybe you can make fun of the
commercialism and marketing and such but
they never do
maybe they got stolen like Wes Craven to
handle it someone who sort of mixes
satire with the traditional horror
cliches you know like the stream or new
nightmare but this this is just ungodly
dumb and really pisses you off and how
much they don't explain or don't explain
very well it's just a pain in my frickin
haunted ass I'm the Nostalgia Critic
pumpkin juice why did I say that because
fucking ending
[Music]
we're swingers
you